[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
we're back walter yes we're going to
continue our
study on the new education yes today
we're going to
go into the solidarity part yeah
let's open with a word of prayer our
heavenly father
we are back again and we ask please that
you bless us
in our discussion and once again
enlighten our minds with the holy spirit
that we can discern what is right and
what is wrong
in jesus name amen amen
one little word and it
is flowing from so many pens these days
yes the little word called solidarity
now i wonder whether this little word
solidarity
also includes conformity yeah you think
so
and compromise probably yeah but only in
terms of the common good right
correct absolutely so we need to look at
where this new education is leading to
and we had in part one we spoke about
that now let's look at this word
solidarity
we'll start with a video
and then we'll continue from there
reflecting on the dramatic change in the
world over the last year
i paid a visit to bretton woods in new
hampshire where
44 men signed our articles of agreement
in 1944 our founders
faced two massive tasks
to deal with the immediate devastation
caused by the war
and to lay the foundation for a more
peaceful
more prosperous post-war world
at the conclusion of the conference john
maynard keynes
captured the significance of
international cooperation
as hope for the world if we can continue
the brotherhood of men will have become
more than a phrase
he said as we look
forward to welcoming andorra as our
119th member
the work of the imf is testament
to the values of cooperation and
solidarity
on which a sisterhood and brotherhood
of humanity is built today
we face a new bretton woods
moment we know what action
must be taken right now
a durable economic recovery is only
possible
if we beat the pandemic i urge you to
support
production and distribution of effective
therapies and vaccines
to ensure that all countries have access
we can do better than build back
the pre-pandemic world we can build
forward to a world that is more
resilient
sustainable and inclusive
we must seize this new bretton woods
moment i see three imperatives
first the right economic policies
and policies must be for people
covet 19 has underscored the importance
of
strong health systems rising inequality
and
rapid technological change demands
strong education and training systems
to increase opportunity and reduce
disparities
just as the pandemic has shown that we
can no longer
ignore health precautions we can
no longer afford to ignore climate
change
my third imperative if you don't like
this health crisis
we will not like the climate crisis one
iota
since the pandemic began we have
committed over a hundred billion dollars
and we still have substantial resources
from our
one trillion dollars in landing capacity
the doubling of the new arrangements to
borrow and a new round of bilateral
borrowing arrangements
preserves our much-needed financial
firepower
our founders did it
it is now our turn
this is our moment
well my young friend what do you say
about that
well she brought all the aspects in that
we've been discussing
yes so you mentioned them one by one
education
solidarity conforming with the
uh the system that they implement and
what's interesting also for me was
the lending once you go into contract
obviously with them your certain rules
that has to be followed he who pays the
piper
calls the tune isn't that correct
now it's interesting that health is a
very important issue
but it is nothing compared to the
climate crisis that is coming we always
have these stepping stones
you know where are we heading where are
we heading where's the final
step where are we heading so we've got
the the disease then we have the climate
and then we must have the human
solidarity
you know what i was looking at the
picture there of all these
people sitting with masks now we're not
debating here
the importance of the mask or the
non-importance of the mosque that debate
is raging all over the world
but one side issue that you cannot
escape
is the uniformity everybody becomes
faceless we all become part of this
one society in solidarity
to this great enemy that is approaching
us
whether it be a virus or climate change
or whatever that enemy is and the
question
always arises where does the enemy come
from
who controls and defines the enemy
so that's our introduction and she used
the word
solidarity of course so that was the
view of the imf
right the international monetary fund
and now we're looking at the united
nations
the concert was made possible with the
contributions
of and then it gives all the
contributors the pacific tourism
organization
travel foundation australian government
department of foreign affairs new
zealand ministry of foreign affairs
university of the south pacific pacific
cooperation
foundation vodafone pacific pacific
community this was about the pacific
community all the island communities
and they of course also have to be
brought into solidarity
and interesting is the way in which they
bring about
solidarity and does music play a role in
this
definitely didn't we in the previous
episode
also learn that part of entertainment
and jesus theater
music will be playing a big part and the
bible also speaks
the bible says about all kinds of music
will be involved now
we'll be playing hopefully some very
short clips of
their music yes once again for short
clips because
these concerts is like between two and a
half
three hours and sometimes five hours
long yes
um so i hope you reduced them to about
10 seconds yes lest my eardrums and my
sensibilities should be outraged yeah
just to get a feel of what was going on
there okay
it's of course also interesting that the
dignitaries are always
involved all the high ranking
individuals such as prince charles and
all of these and there was that
interesting book that i once referred to
about prince charles that was called the
sustainable prince
so he's been on this bandwagon of
environment and sustainability and
solidarity for a very long time
if you look at watch the full um
ceremony and all these things there's
different leaders always speaking and
everything so we've not put in
we've only had a short little excerpt
but let's have a look at some of these
these issues because it tells us where
we are heading
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen i
was most touched to be asked to speak to
you as you gather for this very special
concert
and i did just want to pay tribute to
the united nations for
bringing us all together in this way
this dreadful pandemic comes at a time
when
as i know only too well the pacific
region is already facing
the accelerating and terrifying impacts
of
climate change come on
just wellington
[Music]
do it
so
[Music]
last
[Applause]
[Music]
is
again
[Music]
well we heard all the same rhetorics
again
starting with covert we will wear moths
we will get a new world order and we
will rise
you know when they say we will rise we
you know what comes to mind is that
grand
mural in the great hall of the united
nations
of the phonics rising from the ashes
and in the occult circles we know of
course that the phonics is lucifer
who will rise upon the ashes and set up
his
his kingdom his one world
government well that was the dream
of the luciferians throughout history
and last time we started with the
gnostic
people and the medicis and
that that dream of a uniform
world was virtually shattered by
protestantism
yes and protestantism
had to be destroyed
500 years and in 2017 for the first time
roman catholicism celebrated together
with protestantism
not because of the reformation but
because of its destruction
it doesn't exist anymore because
solidarity came
in yes now it's time for the new world
rising
out of the ashes the phoenix will
rise now this word solidarity where
everybody is of one mind again
and one way of thinking and snow becomes
black
pope francis on solidarity we must
always
walk in the presence of the lord in the
light of the lord
always trying to live in an
irreprehensible way
solidarity as a moral virtue and social
attitude
born of personal conversion calls for
commitment on the part of those
responsible for
education and formation
and what kind of language is that well
the education part i know
is jesuit but i don't understand the
formation part
now formation to be formed
in a particular image this was the heart
and the core of jesuit teaching of
ignacian
teaching to form a person so that he
conforms so in other words they want to
give you
a teacher which they call a coach
okay and that coach must
instill his virtues and his thinking
upon you
and in these groups of think tanks you
were not to oppose
but to were to accept whatever came
from the so-called coach
so uh spiritual formulation
and spiritual directors and spiritual
directors this is
pure jesuit teaching so they want to
form you into a brainless
creature of conformity and this happens
in
christian education education as well in
churches and i'll put links in to your
lectures that you made on the jesuits
and the counter reformation
those would you interesting links for
people to watch
so yes so they want to
form the thinking
and the individual and as we said that
means
to conform here are some of the top
pope francis solidarity quotes they are
actually 15 we won't go through them
solidarity is drawing closer to your
neighbors
solidarity entails the awareness of
being part of a single body
while at the same time involving a
capacity on the part of each member
to sympathize with others and with the
whole
when one suffers all suffers for
solidarity is no mere ideal
it is expressed in concrete actions and
steps that draw us
closer to our neighbors in whatever
situation they find themselves
so this was pope francis's address to
the heads of state
2017 here's another quote
solidarity is more than a feeling it's a
commitment to the common good
we always have that sneaking in
so in other words if the common good
demands something which is contrary to
your conscience
then solidarity demands it yes
for solidarity is much more than a
feeling
of vague compassion or shallow distress
at the misfortunes of so many people
both near and far
solidarity is a firm and persevering
determination to commit oneself to the
common good that is spiritual formation
you will submit to the thinking of your
superiors
they want to re-educate you because like
they said absolutely
you see something as white and they say
it's black you have to you better say
it's black
a firm and persevering determination to
commit oneself to the common good
that is to say to the good of all and of
each individual because we
are all really responsible for all
because
compassion flows from fraternity
that's why he has this new encyclical as
well
which as we have seen is contrary
to the law of god yes
and he makes no bones about it that
salvation
is a collective it's not an individual
matter
but the bible makes it quite clear that
you will stand before god
as an individual and give an account yes
here's the vatican news pope francis no
one is saved alone pope francis is
inviting leaders of other faiths to work
together
with the gentle strength of faith to end
all
conflicts his appeal comes as part of
his discourse at an
international meeting of for peace held
in rome and organized by the community
of
saint egidio entitled no one is saved
alone
peace and fraternity is that true
no no no you have to be saved
as an individual you have been given the
capacity to choose
absolutely that's what i wanted to say
free choice and i
i have repeated this so many times
freedom of choice is so
important to god that he was prepared
to die for died and if it is so
important to god that he was prepared to
die for it
who is somebody or anybody
who says that you have to
go along with their way of thinking
for the sake of the common good and for
solidarity
because if it is contrary to the law of
god
it is contrary to god's will
and it has consequences
now there have been some really
fascinating meetings that have taken
place
here is pope francis at the
international meeting of prayer for
peace at rome's
capital on hill square on october 20
and some very interesting things
transpired there what can you tell us
well there's different religions that
came together
and some of them even have
worshipped in their own places
but they all had solidarity in getting
together on the same
day well let's have a look at what
transpired
that meeting he said contained a
prophetic seed
that by god's grace had gradually
matured
through unprecedented encounters
acts of peacemaking and freshness
initiatives
of fraternity he noticed that since that
meeting
many painful events have taken place at
times
in the name of religion but that we also
acknowledge the fruitful steps
undertaken
since then in inter-religious dialogue
this is a sign of hope that encourages
us to continue cooperating as brothers
and sisters
he said recalling the document on human
fraternity for world peace and living
together
which is signed with the grand imam of
al-hazar
ahmad al-tayeb in 2019
but francis also referred to his
just-released encyclical
fratelli tutti in which he reiterates
that the commandment
of peace is inscribed in the depth of
the religious traditions
now let us again make it quite clear
that we believe
in freedom of conscience and that
everybody has the right to believe
according to the dictates of his
conscience
but nobody has the right to
enforce a solidarity in religious
matters
when it is contrary to one's conscience
not even
for the common good correct matthew 10
verse 34 says quite plainly think
not that i have come to send peace on
earth
i came not to send peace but the sword
in other words the very variance that we
have in the world
leads to contemplation
and contemplation leads to searching for
truth
and the bible makes it quite clear that
if you search for truth with your whole
heart
yes you will find it correct so
variance is not necessarily a bad thing
but then we have to qualify it like
martin luther said let the minds clash
but the fists hold still correct
on 17 october 20 pope francis to
participate in the international prayer
meeting for peace
and let's see what they said about it
pope francis to participate in
international prayer meeting for peace
on tuesday 20 october pope francis will
participate in an international prayer
for peace initiative entitled
no one is saved alone peace and
fraternity
the community of saint egridio that is
preparing
to host its 34th meeting inspired by the
historic
inter-religious encounter wanted by
saint john paul ii
in 1986 said it had promoted this
international meeting of prayer for
peace and the spirit of assisi
and pope francis's encyclical fratelli
tutti
so on tuesday afternoon the religious
leaders will pray
separately in venues across the city
pope francis the patriarch of
constantinople
pathology one and other orthodox and
protestant representatives in the
basilica of saint mary
in arakuli jews in the synagogues of
rome
muslim buddhists and representatives of
other eastern religious
in the capitol line museums the
interreligious ceremony and the capital
line
foresees the participation of many
international names
such as ursula von lyon president of the
european commission
and president sergio matarella of
italy a minute of silence in memory of
the victims of the pandemic and all
wars will conclude the event
now there's nothing wrong with people
praying
and they're praying in different venues
and there's nothing wrong with
people praying in different venues
but where is this leading to it's
leading
to a uniformity of thinking
in terms of the common good yes in some
way there's going to be a compromise
there must be a compromise but we cannot
speak doctrine
we can only speak common good
testimonies for the church volume 2 page
light precious light shines upon god's
people
but it will not save them unless they
consent to be
saved by it fully live up to it and
transmit it to
others in darkness this is the
commission of the church
when you have a meeting of solidarity of
this nature
this element has to be suppressed it
can't yeah
it cannot exist right
god calls upon his people to act it is
an
individual work of confessing and
forsaking sins and returning
unto the lord that is needed one cannot
do this work
for another so what does
this statement do in comparison with the
other statement that you cannot be saved
alone
it's directly opposite it's the exact
opposite right
so we have two mindsets
that are clashing now the fact that the
two mindsets might have many sub
organizations is irrelevant there are
only two mindsets
and they are on a collision course yeah
and compromise will have to be made to
get them
to walk together absolutely but it is an
individual worker
and you have a commission and the
commission
is that you have to follow the dictates
of the gospel
and not the dictates of the common good
if if they are
in variance with one another now my
brother here's a very interesting little
video
it's by the world economic forum so it's
a very good source
not a conspiracy it's just a fact
and it has eight predictions for the
world in 2030
which i hope will definitely be a wrong
date
yeah i don't think i'd be able to last
that long
with this planet as it is at the moment
so i hope that the lord's promise is
that for the
said this time will be shortened
will come to pass but uh solidarity of
course is our topic
and we will see what these ad
predictions are very interesting
[Music]
well what do you make of that
well the first one was very interesting
yeah
you will own nothing nothing and you'll
be happy
you'll be happy yeah because you own
nothing doesn't that sound a lot like
for teletutti oh yes that is fratelli
tutti
so they're predicting that the catholic
social doctrine
will become a reality
now what does the tenth commandment say
thou shalt not covet thy what neighbor's
goods or his wife or anything uh
does that imply that the neighbor has
goods
yes so how can you cover
something that's not yours that's not
your or that if he doesn't own anything
and you don't anything nobody know owns
anything
all right so you can't cover it now
coveting was a big problem
with the rebellion in heaven because
there was
an illuminated gentleman there who
coveted the throne of god right yes
who wanted to be like the most high it
started off with coveting
did rome change the tenth commandment
yes it split it into two
does rome claim that it is the sole
owner of everything
yep now we must actually do a talk about
that
because it's fascinating that god also
claims to be the owner of everything
is he not the owner of a thousand the
cattle on a thousand hills yes so god
owns
everything isn't it god who gives you
the power to become
rich the bible says so
in other words god claims that he owns
everything
and he empowers people
or makes it possible for them to
possess things right
the other one also claims to be the
owner of all the cattle on a thousand
hills
because otherwise he couldn't have been
so presumptuous
as to show christ all the kingdoms and
say bow down to me and i will give them
to you
correct so only someone who is
presumptuous
and claims to own something which he
doesn't own
could do something like that to the god
of the universe right
so we have a very interesting story then
you have the story of course of nabot's
vineyard
and we've discussed all that we do not
have to go into that so you will own
nothing
you will rent everything yeah and who
will you rent it from
exactly who's owning it somebody must
own it
if you rent it right don't you pay rent
to an owner
so in other words you will have been
disinherited and somebody else will have
been
empowered yeah now it'll probably be
the mega corporations that are empowered
and employ you and you will receive
a state funding
are we heading in that direction already
definitely
and they're saying that everybody must
get a basic wage everybody must get
exactly the same
so you will be disempowered and
then you will be totally dependent
on that source of income now
do you think that source of income could
come with certain
strings attached of obedience for
example
definitely like we said earlier also the
same with the
it's already you are bound
by the rules of the bank that you borrow
money from
correct all right here's another one do
the chinese
already have a system
implemented where they control their
society with a point system
yes and that if you do not conform
absolutely to their wishes
then suffer the consequences correct
the covet 19 um we'll get to that part
but also your apps
stuff will be regulating you if you have
a system like this where you have
nothing you own nothing that means
somebody else
owns it because you are renting it
and you are getting your basic income
and then you will conform to all the
rules and regulations and all companies
will have to conform as well because
they will be heavily taxed
it says there will be a carbon tax do we
have a carbon tax already yes
our country yes everybody if you if you
well when you used to fly didn't you pay
a carbon tax and you're in your ticket
where does that money go to somewhere in
the cloud
it goes to the united nations it funds
the united nations right
so we will have a system of fraternity
where you fit into your slot and that is
exactly what we had in the middle ages
as we discussed in a previous one so
this world of conformity is depicted as
a very happy world
yeah everybody's happy yes and it you
know
if you own nothing then you have nothing
to worry about and you don't have
sleepless nights
maybe everybody is also happy because
they're conforming
ah but here's another question
do you have a sense of responsibility
when you own nothing no let's take a
a page out of the communist era
when people were shoved into high rises
were these maintained immaculately and
beautified or were they totally
disintegrated to the point
of depraved poverty
everybody was equally poor exactly was
that happiness
does it uh does it add to incentive for
example
no so this new education is
rather new but it's not new it's been
practiced
all over the world in many many places
now here is a a ted talk
and run us through this there was a ted
talk concert
like we've seen that the united nations
had a concert for
um unity they talked at a concert that
was
called the countdown and it was about
climate change uh-huh and where does
that going to
lead us we'll have to find that out so
we're building up right so we want the
solidarity
number one you start off the solidarity
by making everybody equal nobody owns
anything
and you rent everything and you conform
to whatever society has decided for you
by the way if you own nothing and you
rent everything or you're going to be
part of the decision-making process
no no somebody will decide for you
and we already know who those are who
will be deciding for you right
is they also said the united states
won't be the
number one power in the world
because that is steeped in the
judeo-christian culture
and solidarity means that that can't
swing the scepter any longer in actual
fact this is a
war against the bible and against the
god of the bible
he has to be slotted in they're not
going to eliminate him entirely
but just give him a slot amongst many
my bible says there's no other name
under heaven and earth whereby you can
be saved except the name christ jesus
but let us look at this because here we
have some dignitaries
today marks the beginning of counting
down to zero
on the emissions that are warming up our
planet
it's a real honor to introduce for his
first ted talk
prince william
whilst our generation represents just a
blip in the lifetime of these
magnificent oaks
we have the power and potential to
ensure that they
and all life on earth thrive for another
thousand
years and more but only if we now
unleash the greatest talents of our
generation
to repair our planet we have no choice
but to succeed thank you
okay everyone i'm in i hope you are too
go find that list on the countdown
website
use your voice and figure out what steps
are right for you today
now here's a question we haven't yet
discussed
how do faith and climate intersect
one person can certainly answer that
question better than anyone else
he has made the twin crisis of climate
and inequality the central pillars of
his action
since he was elected in 2013 as the head
of the roman catholic church
and his voice talks to believers as well
as to non-believers
he's joining us now from his private
study in vatican city
it's an honor and a privilege to
introduce
his holiness pope francis
request
[Music]
a
that was quite a mouthful and he gets
the celebrities
and the important people to
introduce him now
it's interesting that those companies
that do not conform will have to
disappear
yeah and they will be punished
and those that conform will be
rewarded and the young people must be on
board
and you say there was a lot of music
involved with this yes there was also
again i didn't cut it in but there was
music the whole time
it was a five hour five
odd concert
but the basic story remains the same
same we're going to go towards
common good everybody has to be on board
everybody's in solidarity solidarity
and uh the young people that he was
referring to
i wonder whether he is talking about
greta tonberg
now we we've showed previous pictures
with her closing one eye
but uh here are some new ones right yeah
and what's interesting is the one on the
right
she's holding up a digital currency
coin so it seems to me
that this kind of portrayal
in pictures carries a subliminal message
people will say that's a conspiracy
theory
but it's there in plain sight right
yeah and we've discussed her connections
and her parents connections with the
club of rome and those things
before and we are heading
in a particular direction and we know
what prophecy says
and we must never forget what prophecy
says
otherwise this will just be background
noise
we have to look through the glitter
through the glitz
through the lies through the process
to see where we are heading
well one of the things is a common pass
this comes from the world economic forum
the challenge
as countries around the world work to
overcome the covet 19 pandemic and
restart their economies and tourism they
all
face the challenge of how to reopen
their borders
and allow international travel to resume
while protecting their population's
health
the current patchwork of policies and
ever-changing
border entry and health screening
requirements has made international
travel incredibly complex leaving
airlines and border agencies uncertain
about the validity of
test results and passengers unsure
of what is being asked of them now
that's a very interesting point
isn't it interesting how the tests have
been so
variable and that the you know some
trust them and some don't trust them
so if the tests are so problematic
what could save the day a vaccine maybe
yeah
the solution a common pass
aims to develop and launch a standard
global model to enable people to
securely
document and present their covert 19
status
either as test results or and eventual
vaccination status
to facilitate international travel and
border crossing
while keeping their health information
private
now my young brother do you think it's
going to stay with covet 19 or will
there be something else on the horizon
as well
i'm sure it will be something else what
about compliance to
environmental conditions yep
i'm sure it will it's interesting for me
if you get like you said just
now look at the end where we
might be heading at prophecy and you
have the background
then this whole solution that they give
must be somewhat suspicious to you
absolutely
so this is this is very vague because
this is ever-changing
what is going to be the firm foundation
on which you will be granted
a pass remember the imf
said if we didn't like
this the covet crisis we will not
like the climate crisis one iota
absolutely okay so recognizing
that countries will make sovereign
decisions on border entry and health
screening requirements including whether
or not to require
tests of what type of test you require
commonpass serves as a neutral platform
which creates the
interoperate needed for the various
travel
bubbles to connect and for countries to
trust one another's data
by leveraging global standards
now that brings the chinese model back
to mind
there are so many criteria to which you
have to conform
in order to get a travel pass and it's
not just covet 19
it's how often you disobey a traffic
light yes
it's how often you do this that or the
other
that the state does not agree with right
and eventually could your religious
convictions play a role or any one of
those yep
surely it's just the stepping stone it's
logical
yeah because it's not going to stay with
covet 19. they're already talking about
cover 23
now the world economic forum is very
very active in all of this
and we've seen some very interesting
speeches which
sound like secret society speeches
yeah but here we have one of their
releases
this new initiative could let people
travel around the world safely
while keeping their health data private
let's just look at what their plan is
commonpass is a platform that lets
people safely and securely collect their
health information
whether it is a negative covid test
result
or eventually a record of a coveted
vaccination
manage that information control it
themselves and then
be able to let that information be used
to demonstrate that they
have had a negative test or they have
been vaccinated so they can get on an
airplane
or travel to another country for
countries
it gives them the ability to actually
know confidently that this person who
wants to come visit them
can actually safely be admitted into
their country
without risk of exposing
other people in the country to to covet
[Music]
if you put yourself in a traveler's
shoes
you know people want to travel but they
don't want to and frankly shouldn't have
to
hand out their sensitive health
information to every
airline they want to fly every country
they want to visit every airport they
want to travel through and so i think
the
the balance that needs to be achieved is
say hey how can we
give let's say a country or an airline
the comfort they need to know that this
person
is safe to travel or safe to enter a
country
without having to reveal sensitive
health information
[Music]
my brother that sensitive health
information is on the travel path
and it says you have been cleared for
travel
and that is all that the individual at
the point of entry needs to know
now what are those criteria which enable
them to say
you have been cleared for travel right
yeah
and that data will be governed by the
organization that keeps this data
absolutely and uh the criteria that fit
into that data will be determined by
whom
by them by somebody right it must be
somebody it's not going to be you
okay so is this a system
of absolute surveillance yes
yes well here is the president of
south africa and let's see what he had
to say
as we have said before we need to
utilize
various tools in our coronavirus toolbox
to fight this virus we can also use
technology to fight the virus
i call on each of
every south african to join the seven
hundred thousand south africans
who have downloaded covet alert as a
mobile app the covered alert
app can notify you if you've been
exposed to the virus whether it is in a
taxi
a shopping mall or a social gathering
and it does so without sharing your
location or
any of your personal information
the app is zero rated by mobile networks
so it won't cost you anything to protect
yourself
and others by downloading this app
you help to make the virus visible
and break the chain of transmission
we would like therefore to appeal to all
organizations to encourage their staff
to encourage their visitors to download
the app
when they enter their offices their
shops
their schools universities or other
enclosed facilities or spaces
south africa has also been appointed as
a co-chair
of the global acta initiative that is
facilitating access
to innovative interventions including
vaccines for all countries
countries are going to have to allocate
funding
so that they can be access to vaccines
to prevent
the further spread of the virus
in recognition of our country's
manufacturing capacity
one of the leading pharmaceutical
companies in the world
johnson johnson has entered into a
preliminary agreement with a local
company
aspen farmer care to manufacture
and package its candidate vaccine
aspen has capacity to manufacture 300
million doses of the
candidate vaccine at its nelson mandela
bay plant
in port elizabeth this
life-saving medical product will be
needed across the world
and it will be manufactured here in
south africa
by south african workers
and obviously we are bidding
very hard to have an uptake
of the product that will be produced
here in our own country
this is in addition to the progress made
by biovec
a local biopharmaceutical company that
is in partnership with the south african
government
biovac is in advance discussion with an
international vaccine manufacturer
that would also enable it to locally
manufacture
a covered 19 vaccine to ensure
sufficient supply for our country and to
our continent
was this only concerning travel
no didn't he mention other facilities
shopping
universities anything anything
now what does the bible say if you do
not accept
the mark of the beast then you will not
be able to buy or sell
now obviously covet 19 is not the mark
of the beast nor is the vaccine
uh the mark of the beast but these are
stepping stones yes
so we have to find the ultimate step
where we are heading to right yes
everything is in place
so let's have a look at the next step
there have been a number of initiatives
of what has been called a green sabbath
and here is a web page the green sabbath
project
this was created by a professor
involved in relations with the jewish
religion etc and he's asking is there
nothing you can do about the environment
nothing maybe one of the best things you
can do one day every week
do nothing take a weekly day of rest
make it a real sabbath for you for earth
don't drive don't shop
don't build take a walk eat with friends
play or read with your kids sing
meditate
increasing numbers of people see the
wisdom of observing
a technology shabbat
a break from all devices with screens
vegota colombia has introduced car free
sundays
that the population savors when israeli
cities shut down for the jewish holiday
of yom kippur the day of atonement
nitrogen oxide pollution in the air
decreases for the day
by 70 to 99 percent
the sabbath is said to be a foretaste of
the world to come
babylonian talmud berakot 57b
i'm wondering what does the babylonian
talmud have to do
with this issue literally
if you care about our future about your
well-being
observe a real sabbath day of rest it
helps cultivate
community self-discipline in a calm
contentment one powerful weapon
in the fight against environmental
deterioration and climate disaster may
just be an
age-old spiritual technology
it could be merely a question of doing
nothing see the call to action written
by our founder
and director jonathan schach the sabbath
in an
era of climate change
now the comet good will require that all
humanity
reach a common accord in terms
of this day right correct
to make the maximum input we all have to
work together right
yeah for now like we said it might be
stepping stones
so even in this initiative they're
they say you can have any day
but we'll see how it progresses but even
there they talk about a car free sunday
right
then you have the sabbath in an era of
climate change
and he writes here the same author
given their continued widespread
influence biblical religion
and its offshoots offer one particular
compelling promising solution
shabbat the sabbath day of race
observing a truly full weekly shabbat
doing nothing
as it were offers an effective action
that one can take now to help heal our
environment
since the heavily environmentally
damaging developed
world is made up mostly of monotheists
the impact of eliminating most emissions
once weekly
would be particularly important that's
interesting monotheism has something to
do with it
judaism and christianity called the
shabbat an obligation
if we really believe that radical change
in our behavior is necessary for
environmental reasons i
certainly do then don't these reasons
make sabbath along with all other
environmental solutions and
obligation now we're talking about
obligation those who are indifferent to
religion dislike it
or oppose it may well shout in distress
at such a religious approach
yet it is noteworthy how the new green
values
such as cooperativeness mindfulness
simplicity temperance respect for nature
overlap with values religion
at its best has thought for millennia
if a billion or more monotheists and
interested hindus buddhists
indigenous people atheists and agnostics
observe a weekly
shabbat seriously for the near term
imagine
how much of a break we would be giving
the world that sustains us
a world that desperately needs some rest
this is a very common theme and it
brings together like he said
even if you're religious or not
there is overlapping themes that brings
you together that
the green people and the religious
people
and the common good requires it that's
it there's another movement
the world action on climate and health
organization
waco and it says quite frankly that for
the sake of the common good
we must do whatever it takes to reverse
the climate change emergency
thus we call on all governments
worldwide to ban the use of
red meat also we want to see less
private cars on the road and the use of
public transportation
should be encouraged needless to say all
fossil fuel companies should immediately
stop drilling
in addition we must recreate a new
economic system
that is environmental friendly
more importantly we need a universal
weekly day of rest that is protected by
law
for all nations
to give our planet and bodies a rest and
we have
seven years to do all that or mankind
will be
extinct now modern
this organization is a little bit more
of a fringe organization and it's not
quite clear exactly how they function or
where they come from
yeah it's difficult if also if you go to
the
website provided there's no website
actually
but it looks like they're quite active
on twitter and facebook so
yeah it was just putting it out there to
show what
type of movements and or stepping we can
get to
yes so it's not the you know
organization that the united nations
speaks about and all of these things
but he has some interesting points he's
talking about
a law for all nations
and he's talking about a universal
weekly day
a universal weekly day and he's saying
that we only have seven years less
now really this time setting should stop
because our anti-conspiracy people will
get nervous breakdowns
but i certainly hope he's right
so let's see where this is heading
there's some more of what he has to say
extraordinary climate webinar series
restoring a universal
weekly rest day for human fraternity and
the planet so here he calls it
a zero carbon sunday so he's specifying
the day of course
that needs to have this rest
so is there this movement towards a
sunday rest yeah there's all everywhere
these movements
here is the church times and this is
uh an article about climate sunday
52 sundays to rescue creation
so that means keeping the sunday every
week right 52
sundays in a year you remember we did
the jubilee for the earth
yes this is also in that same category
runs to with that whole initiative
okay so the bishop of salisbury the
right reverend nicholas
halton has described the climate sunday
initiative
launched this weekend by churches
together in britain and ireland as a
brilliant resource to help parishes
reach the target of zero emissions by
and campaign for more government action
the climate sunday initiative was
announced in june
by a coalition of churches and charities
calling for
more action on global warming
this sunday 6 september is the first
in a year in which individual churches
are encouraged to choose their own
creation sunday the object is for
churches in britain and ireland to use
climate-focused services
to explore the link between theological
and scientific reasons
for looking after the environment there
is also a campaign
for more action on the environment from
the government
and a challenge to congregations to
commit to further action to halt
climate change spreading the initiative
across
the whole year is intended to make it
accessible to every church
calendar and tradition more than
700 churches from a range of
denominations have registered
already now it says there
accessible to every church calendar and
tradition
is that correct that's not correct
how can it make it accessible to every
church tradition
if some keep sunday and some don't keep
sunday
more than 700 churches from a range of
denominations have registered already i
could not register for this no it
wouldn't work for us
won't work for me i keep the sabbath of
the lord they're keeping a sabbath of
tradition
martin just to wrap this up we see that
solidarity
is leading us to a particular point
now for the religions in order
for them to accept this we need another
final climactic occurrence
yeah now they're talking about building
the
third temple right and the theology
that the jesuits have put out there in
the world to counter the reformation
theology on the antichrist
is that he will make his appearance yeah
or that the christ will come
to the temple and that he
will then there proclaim his kingdom
and we know from the spirit of prophecy
that he will
proclaim that the sabbath has been
changed
so this must take place while this
melting pot
is on the way so let's just look at
this third temple issue before we wrap
it up
so let us just look how they're going to
fit this all in here's a
an article on coronavirus
and it says that the pandemic
as a trigger for the first temple
and does it mean the current corona
crisis could herald the third
temple the trigger for the construction
of the first temple in jerusalem was an
epidemic
that broke out as a result of king david
mismanagement of a national census
now some are wondering to what extent
the current pandemic will play a role in
the building of the third temple
the timing and the choice of location
for the first temple on mount moriah
were both related to david's senses
though it would of course be his son
solomon who built the shrine
but it was david who purchased the holy
site in jerusalem and built an altar
there to the god of israel in order to
bring an
end to the epidemic now what these
people are saying
is that there must be a universal
involvement here because the
epidemic is universal but that epidemic
only affected israel yes because of a
bad choice
because david didn't trust in the might
of god
to deliver him from his enemies he
wanted to count the people to see what
his strength was
yes he forgot that his strength came
from god
i'm wondering whether these people are
making the same mistake
now martin this temple
is going to be an important issue right
for sure it's going to be a climactic
occurrence
on the earth has there been a dry run
somewhere in the world have they
practiced the this initiative
yes in sao paulo in brazil
they built a temple temple of solomon
they built the temple of solomon and did
it attract uh
world leaders and thousands of people
from all over the world pilgrims
different
faiths coming together and can we say
this is a precursor for another great
event that will bring the whole world
together was the issue of solidarity an
important one then
yes so will the issue of solidarity be
important in the end
let's have a look at this they discussed
this
major this was about
a while back 2014 that it was unveiled
the temple uh-huh let's have a look at
the dry run
the temple of solomon the new
headquarters of the universal church of
the kingdom of god was inaugurated in
sao paulo
with president dilma rousseff and many
of the highest authorities in the
country present
it was a special day the sanctuary is
the biggest in brazil
and one of the biggest in the world it
was expected that more than 15
000 people would attend
[Music]
the main facade of the temple is the
height of an 18-storey building
and is a mosaic of stone brought from
hebron
then the ark of the covenant was taken
into the new temple
in the same way that priests did this in
israel
bishops and pastors carried the ark
inside it
are symbols of the christian faith and
the traditions of the jewish people
[Music]
the procession was followed by thousands
of people
trumpets announced the arrival of the
ark
the ark was received in the main hall
a space for ten thousand people which
was completely full
[Music]
it was a replica of the ark used in the
past
to keep the tablets of the ten
commandments which represent the
presence of god for
all people the president attended the
entire service
at the end of the ceremony dilma visited
the other areas of the temple
dedicated to the preservation of the 12
tribes
of israel
[Music]
then she saw the replica of the
tabernacle which was used for centuries
in the desert
to worship god
before leaving the president spoke about
the importance of the temple
of solomon it is a house of prayer
and a house of prayers a house of peace
a house of harmony
so it has great importance for brazil in
the sense that it represents
symbolizes values the colombian who
planned his trip for two years
says that it is a privilege to be here
there is a light something really
powerful
i felt the presence of god
this is one of the caravans of pilgrims
from africa
people from different countries people
came from the interior
traveling for four or five days to
arrive here and experience the temple of
solomon
the faithful approached the altar this
was one of the moments of greatest
emotion
the ceremony was attended by
representatives of different religions
and from all parts of the world in the
same
faith
a forerunner of things to come maybe
all the nations together it's
interesting that you said that the ark
contained
symbols of christianity and judaism
although originally of course it didn't
contain
anything but the ten commandments the
pot of manna
and aaron staff but we are heading for
very fascinating times
isaiah chapter 66 verse 5
hear the word of the lord ye that
tremble at his word
your brethren that hated you that cast
you out for my name's sake
said let the lord be glorified but he
shall appear to your
joy and they shall be ashamed
in matthew 10 22 we read and you shall
be hated for all men for my name's sake
but he that endureth to the end shall be
saved
i believe the world is on an express
train to disaster the new education
is nothing other than a universal
jesuit education the new solidarity
is a solidarity in principles
which you will not find in the bible
and the rules and the regulations that
govern this
new world order this common good
will be such that they directly
contradict the law of god
and god's people have to make a choice
and either we sit in solidarity
or we have one god
one faith one baptism
that's our choice let's pray
heavenly father we are living
in the very tips of the toes of daniel's
statue
and all that we have spoken about is in
the news media
everything that is written in prophecy
is portrayed on the screens that people
watch
on a daily basis may the god of all
comfort be with us
as we head into the final moments of
earth's history
and may we be empowered through his
grace to make the right choice
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you